我是王希
然后今天开始我们的第19讲
那么在开奖之前的话
大家有没有注意到今天我有什么区别对吧
大家看看我今天穿的什么
对我们的社区的T恤终于印出来了
这个我还我今天还特别高兴
因为课程准备到最后几分钟的时候
课程组告诉我说我们的T恤已经印出来了
所以我迫不及待的就穿上去了
给大家看一看
大家觉得效果怎么样
看看自己还不错吧
然后那个我们那个课程组的小伙伴的话
会尽快安排给我们的
就是所有被抽中的同学
还有我们社群的热心的同学们
还有什么
还有我们作业做得非常那个好的
同学都给大家寄过去
大家还记得上节课我们讲过
就是说作业中的话
大家只要做完两个作业的话
我们就会把T恤送给大家
因为也是想鼓励大家
一起去参与到我们的课程中来
说实话啊
我们也不知道有什么目的
反正我觉得能跟着我们一起
把这个课程跟到现在的同学都是好汉
因为我自己想了一下
我们的课程现在总时长已经接近50个小时了
然后我觉得我在大学读书的时候
让我一个学期上一门课
我有的时候还很难坚持不逃课
所以说我觉得能坚持下来的都是很厉害的
这个选手
那么其实呢说实话
我们自从那个就是上几节课
说鼓励大家在我们的B站上面去留言的时候
其实收到了很多很多大家的声音
真的很感动
有的时候我们很enjoy
看大家跟我们讲什么东西
确实特别让我有感触的是
说一其实准备这个课的话
我们蛮辛苦的
然后我每天都在想要争取下一周不上课
我又可以偷懒了
但是的话呢真的到临近尾声的时候
还真的有点舍不得说
哎呀我每个星期能跟大家打个招呼
告诉大家我们学的一些东西
想要一些东西
好像已经成为了我们生活的一种习惯
所以的话呢呃我我我们也在想说
后面怎么样子能够继续帮助到大家
这里面
我就想正好跟大家好长时间没有讲一件事情
就是说那个大家我们好久没有讲
我们的PICO引擎了
实际上的话呢
最近整个课程组在非常忙的准备课件
但是的话呢我们那个忘了
这个就是说呃跟大家讲皮克罗引擎
其实我们一直也在偷偷的在去做一些新的模块
争取能够帮助到我们的社群
跟大家汇报一下
现在我们正在做的事情
第一个的话呢就是我们把我们的这个r chi
也就是我们面向graphics底层的东西
我们又把它这个就是又更新了一个一个
重新的结构
因为以前我们RH还写的不够专业
我们这次的话呢
争取给他换的稍微专业那么一点点的RH
这样的话能够未来大家想要移动端移植啊
大家想往这个其他的甚至游戏主机移植的话
提供这样一个一个帮助
另外一个的话呢就是说呃
包括特别是对于DX12啊
对于这个metal特别是metal的支持要变得更好一点
另外一个的话呢
就是哎这个是我觉得非常的这个
非常的amazing的一件事情
就是我们前两天我们有个同学这个发奇想
我们给我们的PICO还写了一个GPU particle
也就是说虽然你看了这个图上
你看不清楚
现在我还配视频来不及了
然后呢
但是的话我们是真的实现了一个非常简单的GPU
PARC系统
这样的话诶大家可以在皮克罗里面可以去看看
这个GPU particle该怎么去实现
当然那个我们做的是非常简单的
给大家做了个框架
那么有同学们
如果想要PICO做个自己的小游戏啊
比如说做一个你自己的毕设的话
我相信你可以秒杀那些没有用过PICO的小伙伴
因为我们104的精神就是人均一个
这个就是开源引擎嘛
然后另外一个的话呢
就是说呃我们现在的话呢
就是在这个就是我们的皮克罗引擎里面
还加了一个小小的debug做系统
为什么加了个debug做系统呢
因为现在好多同学们跟我们讲说
他们想要PICO做自己各种各样的小应用啊
想要做自己的小游戏
那实际上的话呢
如果你真的作为一个稍微复杂点的开发的话呢
你就一定要有这个debug做系统
而且这个系统呢写不好
可能会把性能写得非常低
所以的话呢我们就加入了这样的一个
第八个做系统
然后争取再给我们一两周的时间
因为我们这是开源的代码
所以我们不好意思把代码写得特别的丑
所以呢我们会做一些code review
如果我们觉得质量可以的话
也给大家
所以说不定的话就是说我们的104课程啊
这个告一段落之后的话
在新的课程还没开始之前
我们可能会持续性的去对皮克洛进行更新呃
到时候零四课程的可能
games的视频号我们不能用了
我们可能会到时候大家可以在B站上找到
我们自己的视频号
然后的话呢我们也会定期的给大家讲一下
皮克罗的一些
比如说结构讲解呀
或者是皮克O的一些大家要的什么功能
我们怎么去开发
跟大家一起
能帮助大家就真的实现我们这个课程的口号
就人均一个自研引擎对吧
那么另外一个的话呢就是上一节课的话呢
其实同学们在那个我们各个QQ
那个就是微信群里面讨论的真的是非常的热烈
我自己都没有想到
然后呢
这里面的话呢就是同学们也问我们的一些问题
这是我们从大家问题里面挑出来的
第一有同学们问我们说诶有没有游戏
它混合了真同步
和这个就是说呃那个状态同步的啊
其实是有的啦
就是大部分的真正的游戏的话
很多时候都是这样
举个例子吧
比如说我们玩一个MOBA游戏
MOBA游戏呢
真正的游戏的game play
就是你进入到一起游戏的时候
很多时候大家会用的是真同步
但是呢你进入到游戏大厅呀
比如说你看到一群人在那跑来跑去啊
那时候玩家特别多啊
而且又对游戏的逻辑要求不是那么严格的话
其实状态同步就可以了
所以说其实很多的实战性游戏的时候
都会把两种状态给混合在一起
那还有同学问我们一个问题
就是说哎
如果将来以后整个游戏都变成了语音游戏了
我们是不是就不用学这个网络同步
这些东西了啊
这个怎么说呢
这件事情首先还没有发生对吧
我们还没有看到真正的云游戏引擎
那么我也不敢说的特别的断言
但是呢我觉得肯定了
大家如果都上了云游戏之后
那很多网络同步啊
包括今天这节课我们会再给大家讲的这个防反
做反作弊啊
会简单很多
但是呢我个人觉得就是说
如果是真的是超大规模的游戏的话
你还是需要大量的这个状态同步的
因为我不可能把所有的用户的输入
直接连到我的server端
你前面还是有很多的类似于client的东西
它可能做的比较轻
所以呢
特别是如果用户从不同的地域接近来的话
但是前端还是有些节点来进行这样的处理
所以我个人认为状态同步还是必要的
在整个这个游戏世界中的话
可能是同一个真同步
那说不定真的就像大家讲的
那个世界是一个真核状态
同时混合的一个状态
但这个里面的话呢
我觉得现在还在一个呃
大家在做很前沿的探索阶段
所以说啊我是我相信再过几年会逐渐的清晰
然后最后一个同学也问我们一个问题
就是说诶就是说如果是不是真同步了
就没有人作弊了
其实上节课我已经讲过了
就是原则上来讲
真同步确实能够防范很多的作弊
但是呢也不能够防范掉所有的作弊
举个例子
比如说上次也讲过
比如说我把地图全开了对吧
什么战争迷雾完全没有用了
比如说我打撸啊撸对吧
对方出什么英雄对吧
对方在干什么事情
我一清二楚
其实如果是真同步的话
我确实可以做这样一件事情
为什么呢
因为他所有的状态全部同步到这
我们是一模一样的那个逻辑
如果没有做必要的防范的话
我可能连他在商店里出了什么装备
我都知道很清楚对吧
所以说啊这这个东西的话呢
也就也就是说很多事情
他都是就这也是做网网游的
非常复杂的一件事情
就是说因为你架不住
就是大家会从各个角度去尝试攻击这个系统
好的好
那就是我们这一次整个社群的一个反馈
在开始今天这节课之前的话呢
我给大家做个简单的预告
首先的话这一节课讲完
我们网络课讲完之后呢
我们会暂停一周
然后后面会开始我们的高级课程
那为什么我们要暂停一周呢
因为我们的高级课程
每一节课实际上都是非常非常重的一节课啊
其实我自己压力很大
因为我们选了三个topic的话
应该来讲都是分量很重的
而且技术密度非常高
我还不是特别有信心诶
我第一个
我自己能不能把这个知识掌握得足够的准确
足够的到位
第二个就是说能不能在课件上给大家讲清楚
比如说我们的第一节课的话
我会给大家讲真正的面向数据编程
就d o p dorange programming和job system
这个是对于现代高性能引引擎
或者是系统开发来讲的话
是一个非常核心的一个架构对吧
那这样的话如果这套体系的话
其实这就像现在很多商业引擎都没有完全做到
比如说我们那个unity著名的ECS对吧
也是在尝试往这个方向去发展
那荣耀其实它的新的那个massive的这个系统
也在做这样的一件事情
这是我们的第一个advance topic
那么第二个advance topic呢
那就是大名鼎鼎的对吧
就是虚幻五的那个NORMAN和拿来night这两个技术
那这两个技术呢
说实话复杂度还是非常非常高的
就是说你了解他的大概可能呢没有那么难
但是你真的去一个一个知识点去理解它
然后能够把他这些东西串到一起的话
其实非常的复杂
真的是要对这些高手还是要保持敬畏之心
就是说这两个技术的话
就是说从他技术概念很早以前就有人提出来
但是还还是很了不起的一件事情
就是大家真的在工业化上面
把这个问题解决掉了
所以啊我也是诚惶诚恐
我说一节课的时间我能不能把它讲清楚
那么第二个的话呢
就是大家诶喜闻乐见的motion matching对吧
这个这个还有什么呢
APPGC就是那个基于pro procedure
generate content对吧
这个也是大家特别喜欢的一个一个内容
但是这里面PGC的话
你的内容其实也是非常的多
而且很多孩子不是不是我特别熟悉的领域
比如说胡迪尼
我用的就不是特别好对吧
那那那这里面的话就有很多东西我们要去准备
所以呢我们也会跟games课程组商量
能不能就是说每节课都能中间空一周
这样的话我们课程组能够进行更充分的准备
当然大家也可以在社区里投票
说我不需要
我就是要三节课连着讲
那我也没办法了
我觉得勉为其难对吧
如果那个games允许我们这样调整
如果大家也支持我们的话
我个人会倾向于就是说每节课花两周时间准备
这样的话能讲得更透一点
因为这几节课都是啊非常的硬
这个里面我要做一个高能预警
前方高能
所以的话呢这是我们在下一个就是整个基础
今天是我们的基础课程的最后一章嘛
然后这三节课呢是我们的高级课程的开始
就未来的话我们有可能会跟games商量
就是啊
这个会可能可能考虑给大家开一个
二零系列的高级课
对不对
但是的话呢我们先拿着三节课给大家做个预热
看看大家喜不喜欢这些东西
那么那如果真的要开高级课的话
请大家允许我们先躺一年啊
躺个半年
我要我要好好的回点血了
OK那所以这个地方呢也给大家做一起讲一下
我们后面的课程安排好的
言归正传
每次开场10分钟回到我们今天的课程
就是继续讲我们的online gaming architecture
那今天讲的呢就是高级的topic
我记得我上节课卖过一个关子对吧
我说虽然我们上节课讲了那么多
还是蛮硬核的东西
连网络技术协议都跟大家讲一下
大家意识到说原来我要做一个online gaming
连网络协议我得自己都得改一改对吧
都得写一写
确实还是还是这个蛮硬的
但当你把这些硬菜全部学完
我也懂了
什么叫真同步
什么叫状态同步
我们是不是就能做一个online gaming呢
在上节课我最后一页
我说唉
大家可能不要高兴的太早
这些都只是foundation当你真正的做个游戏的时候
实际上还有一些很有趣的东西我们没有掌握
那这时候你的游戏做出来
你说能不能联网呢
能够联网
但是你打起来就是很奇怪
所以今天这节课的话呢
是真正的教大家怎么去做网游对吧
那么这个东西的话呢
用一句更简单的话解释
就是说
假设你们你们俩好几个同学们一起做个游戏
分一个团队
如果有同学自告奋勇的把那个online game的basic
那个那个课程里的东西全部实现完之后
你呢就可以很愉快的做那个高级的部分
确实你可以装作它下面的东西都不知道
没关系
那你接下来在上面的话
你来看看你要解决什么问题
OK好
那么今天呢这节课的话呢
我们的structure首先还是从game play上面的要求讲
我们会跟大家讲
就说如何在不同的客户端之间怎么同步
玩家的移动
Character moon replication
那大家想想哇
连网络移动同步这件事情
都要单独作为一个章节来讲对吧
这个听上去好像有点意思了
那么第二个的话呢就是A叫head registrator
简单翻译就是如何在网络游戏的情况下
我能打中敌人
而且能正确的打中敌人
你想想看做一个游戏
你就又不能移动同步
又不能打中敌人
那你这个游戏肯定是不成立的
所以我上节课为什么说
学完上节课还不足以做游戏
就是这个道理
因为这两他是大家首先要掌握的
有了这两盘之后呢
大家基本上就知道怎么就做游戏了
然后接下来第三章节呢
我给大家讲一个诶
我们一个M游戏
就是说很多玩家在一起的这样一个游戏
它不一定是一个MRPG啊
可能是个MOFPS
Whatever
它的网络基础架构大概是怎么架的
它这个其实不是network architecture
实际上是他整个这个啊server端的这个framework
应该怎么去架
但是我们因为时间有限
我们只会跟大家讲这个纲要
让大家知道这个框架
然后呢最后给大家讲一下
诶
这个里面
其实如果你要做这样的一个游戏产品的时候
你最关注的一个东西是什么
诶你也得优化它的带宽
如果带宽不优化
你会发现你的服务器内部都会炸掉
还有呢最后一个也是大家特别关心的
有感感兴趣这个话题就是如何反作弊对吧
那么反作弊的反面是什么
叫作弊
那作弊这件事情呢
我要跟大家高能预警一下
就是说
根据我们国家这个这个信息安全法的规定啊
大家这个非法入侵计算机系统是个违法行为
那大家同学们一定不要试啊
虽然你们知道这些技术
但请你们不要试这个试了之后真的不好
那么最后一个的话呢
我们会荡开一笔跟同学们讲一下
就是说诶
如果我们要做一个非常时下最热热烈的
最火爆的开放大世界对吧
那我们要做开放世界
你最基础的一个架构该怎么去架它呢
当然我们还只是点到为止
但是我觉得也能够帮助同学们去理解和思考
一些有意思的问题
所以这就是我们今天往那个online game
architecture的这样的一个高级篇
跟大家讲的内容怎么样
大家觉得这个课程提纲还是让诸位客官满意吧
好
那接下来的话呢
就是我们开始我们今天课程的正文
首先第一趴的话呢
我们给大家讲一下
就是说角色位移的同步
Replication
replication的意思就是诶我在那边复制出来
这个词
听上去很简单对吧
那为什么这个问题要单独拎出来讲呢
其实啊就是说大家知道在上节课里面
我们讲了这个网络的传输不仅不稳定
还有什么
还有还有lagging
他是老师会有一个latency对吧
我们上节课专门分析了各种的就是延迟
那实际上的话呢
就是我在我的玩一个游戏的时候
我看到别的小伙伴在那个世界里跑来跑去
真实的情况是什么呢
是那个小伙伴自己已经跑到很前面去了
然后呢他需要把自己的状态诶
他首先自己有个tick
它不是随时随地发大家发给自己的服务器
这中间的话从他到服务器是不是有个延迟
所以服务器你看这就是如果那个上面的小伙伴
自己是个蓝色的
那么它同步到中间那个灰色的话呢
就是这个这个服务器服务器比较慢
半拍好服务器
老人家他自身的tick还比我慢的吧
一般服务器我们不讲师个十帧每秒嘛
对不对
好他那个老人家反应过来了
然后再把这个这个状态replicate到我这边
无论你是真同步还是状态同步啊
那我们这边假设你做的是状态同步诶
到我这边
就是我下面最下面那个红色的那个区域的话
是不是变得更慢
而且你看我的那个移动
是不是一个消息来了之后
诶
我傻了
我就走一步
一个消息来我就傻了
走一步
那么当然了
我们说如果延迟特别小对吧
比如说你每个1/10秒或者是1/20秒
有一个
那我看到别人在我的客户端上同步的时候
诶
看看看看看看还行
但是如果大家想象一下
网络讲师LEX就是网络的latency不稳定的时候
我是不是会出现那个人就是一抖一抖一抖一抖
一抖一抖
对不对
所以说我要实现一个最简单的一个
对方移动的同步
那么好像用一个最简单的消息来了
我去更新这件事情好像是不对的
因为整个这个状态看上去就非常的奇怪
所以在这样的一个情况下的话
我们怎么去解决这个同步问题呢
哎这里面我们就祭出我们的
大名鼎鼎的数学工具了
叫什么呢
叫差值对
差值这个东西的话呢
同学们如果在学大学高数的时候对吧
学工程数学的时候应该是耳熟能详了对吧
这个凡事不举就是差值嘛
对不对
只要觉得这个信号不smooth
我们就开始把它smooth一下
怎么smooth
我就跟你差值嘛
那么差值呢有两大流派对吧
第一个流派呢我们叫做INTERLATION内差对对
还有什么呢
extra polation y差值对吧
内插值我们都很熟了
对不对
我们有多个控制点对吧
我们去内差值
大家还记得我们在前面很多会反复提到的
比如说cut more曲线啊
那个BASI样条
BER样条好像比较复杂
它不会控制点
那cut more曲线它就很棒
它可以过所有的控制点对吧
而且让你线条看着非常的光滑
那么或者是我直接就是这个用一段段的折线
我也能插值啊
对不对
内差值大家想到了很正常
但是呢诶在网络同步的时候
我们可能还需要外插值
外插值本质是什么
是预测对吧
比如说根据这个哎我们这个今年的人口出生率
明年的出生率
后年出生率我们可以引引引出一条曲线出来
那是什么
那叫外差值对吧
那么其实在网络这个这个角色位置同步的时候
实际上
这两种差值还扮演了一个很不一样的角色
所以呢这个section我给大家讲一下
就怎么利用差值来让这个这个replicate
这个character动起来看上去更smooth好
那我们先讲这个内插
内插其实非常简单
就是说当我的网络随着时间不停的给我
信息包的时候
这个包可以不均匀啊
他可能一开始密一点
后面因为网络有波动了
我会稀疏一点
没关系对吧
我可以根据你的时间
我把你这些只是给你插出来
而且我可以保证你的平滑性
保证平滑
大家在前面的课程也学过了
其实都比较简单对吧
比如说用cut more曲线
就可以很容易地用一个POLLAMO的计算复杂度
我就可以叉出它的一条光滑的过渡曲线好
那这样的一个方法的话呢
其实在我们在做网络同步的时候
就可以很简单的用下来了
那这里面有一个小小的trick是什么呢
就是说我们以这张图为例啊
就是在这个我们的就是client
在那个就是server端
它如果同步过来别人的一个位置信息
注意啊
这里面我把那个就是那个那个authorize
那个那个client
我把它隐藏掉了
我最上面就直接server了
已经知道那个撞这个角色在S1S二两个状态
就沿着时间轴
那么它同步给我的client的时候呢
实际上已经有一个小小的延迟了
对不对
好
这个时候我要插值
我知道我是在S1S2之间
但是如果我每一次都要去这个急急忙忙的
立刻马上去插值的话
你会出现什么情况
就是你查到了之后
后面的数据还没有来
因为你要跟未来去插值
对不对
除非你做预测
所以呢你要用内插值的时候
有一个很重要的一个trick
就是说我要把从server端来的这个角色的状态
要把它cash到一个buffer里面去
我要稍微加上一点点的offset
然后呢
这样的话
当我在比如说S1和S2之间差值的时候
我有足够的时间等那个S3到我这边来
所以这个time offset其实是非常的重要
而这也是就是内插值的这个游戏引擎
它的一个很典型的一个特征
就是说如果server到client的这个延迟已经是
比如说50ms了
我很可能会要让我本地
我在master
比如说一帧的时间在八分个100ms对吧
我可能又增加了额外的延迟
但是的话呢它的好处是什么呢
就会让我在客户端上看到对方的移动
无比的平滑
这就是内插值的一个很重要的一个特点
就是说它的延迟是会被加剧的
那如果是这样的话
诶我们用这种简单的方法
你会发现当上面的人在动的时候
server慢了
但是到我这边看上去的时候
大家发现没有
其实基本是平滑的
其实这里面是有一个潜在的bug
就是说啊如果那个真正的就是那个authorize那个client
就是那个那个主动在跑的那个对方
他跑跑停停跑跑停
如果说跑停的频率很高的话
其实你用内插值的方法的话
有可能会把这个这个这个这个状态
都可以smooth掉对吧
这就是差值带来的一个额外的你
你不能说它是好处还是坏处
反正它让信号更加的平滑
但是呢我们的人眼很有意思
就是人眼观察这个世界的所有信息的时候呢
我们都会倾向于去看那个就是连续的信号
所以呢这也是就是内插它的道理所在
就是我们一般来讲一辆车也好
一个对面来了一个一个一个一个玩家也好
它的移动如果是光滑的
就相对就是不会急停
急走的话
我们会觉得它移动得更加自然
其实也并不care那个玩家到底是真是怎么弄的
所以这就是内插
但是那一插呢实际上它有一个问题
就刚才我讲的就是诶他加剧我的延迟对吧
而且实际上在两个客户端的话
我们看他的状态一定是严格不一样
对不对
因为我看你的世界慢了
比如说150ms或者200ms
你看我的世界也是200ms
这个200ms你觉得多吗
它也不多
但是呢对于这种高速移动的游戏
举个例子
你玩的是一个赛车游戏对吧
那么这里面举个例子
比如说在这个就是最啊
应该是最
不好意思
我左右不分
我小时候左撇子
然后比如说这是我的左边对
左边的话
大家看左边那个红车
他自己呢是authorized的对吧
他觉得我应该要撞到那个灰色的车
因为灰色的车是同步过来
但灰色车呢他自己是往上跑的
在在在灰色车的客户端
他看到的
首先红车的位置是不是诶稍微滞后一点
所以红车其实没有到我们的交汇点
但是灰车自己觉得自己呢唉我已经跑掉了
因为我的速度总是领先于server嘛
那这样的话就会出现一个很有意思的事情
就是说啊
红车的authorized端认为我已经撞到了灰车
但灰车的authorize端的话呢
他会认为我自己没有撞到那个地方
就是个罗生门了
到底是你们谁说的是对的呢
那这个其实呢就是有interpolation
就是内插值必然会带来的一个
很头疼的一个问题对吧
那么这个问题的话呢
再就是说碰撞没有那么敏感的
比如说我自己个人移动的游戏呢还可以
但是对于你如果开船
比如说我们要做一个像战舰世界的游戏对吧
我们要做一个online的
像GTA这样的游戏
我们互相拿着车开碰碰车玩
那这个问题就变得很很头疼了对吧
所以呢诶这个时候呢
我们就要祭出
我们另外一个可能的法宝是什么呢
叫做extrapolation
外差值什么意思
就是说我既然每个客户端都知道
我得到的消息肯定是比真实的世界晚
那假设我对这个我的latency是有一个估计的话
我是不是可以根据你现在告诉我
你的位置和速度
包括还有加速度对吧
我可以预测
其实如果这个中间比如说这150ms里面
没有任何其他的事情发生的话
你就应该出现
就是就是怎么说呢
这有点相对来讲的
就是说我们的时钟是不对齐的
但是的话我知道此时此刻哎
这跟相关的没有关系啊
我这个混淆了
这其实是牛顿的时空观
是绝对时空无关
不是相对使用感
这个里面不能够做民科
就是在这个绝对时空里面
你此时此地
你在地球的另一端
你实际上是在哪个位置
所以说这个其实呢就是外查的核心原理
就是如果我就像我说的啊
我相信以前我看过一个一个动画片
我还是个这个古装剧
就是啊有一个人收到一封信
他这封信他说诶
说什么什么人要要要要要谋反了
然后呢他收到信之后
他马上就派兵就出去了
然后旁边人问他
你为什么派兵出去
他说这封信技术啊到这边至少要一个月
所以那个人早就已经模仿
好像把那个什么什么已经杀了
所以我这时候应该不用等了
直接去清
就直接去抓它就可以了
其实这就是外差的思想
就是说因为我考虑了信息在路径传递中的
这个latent这个这个时间耽误
所以我预判了别人的行动对吧
怎么样
这个预判了别人的预判
对不对
所以呢我这个时候就会去这个派兵过去了
这个就把这事做了
其实外差的核心思想就是我已经预判到说
你现在其实应该是什么呢
虽然我没有收到你的信息包
这个地方稍微有那么一点点抽象
但这个东西大家一定要理解清楚
为什么呢
这个在后面讲
那个比如说怎么样保证彼此能打通对方
这件事情
想要这种外差的思想就预判了别人的行为
也是非常重要的
好那这个地方的话呢
我们就遇引入一个大名鼎鼎的算法了
叫dead recording
对吧
这个中文翻译我也不知道叫什么算法
这个DEBUCI这个名字听上叫死亡什么什么
这个也挺奇怪的
但是呢他这个算法其实非常大名鼎鼎啊
他以前是航空航海上面的一个概念
什么意思
就是大家想要啊
我一架飞机在空中飞
以前没有GPS的时代的话
我大概知道我七发出发点的位置
然后呢我只有一根空速管
这空速管告诉我相对空气的这个这个相对速度
然后呢我又知道说诶大气风的方向和速度
然后呢我要想去我的目标点
我是不是要规划一条一条路径
去对抗风对我的影响
而且这个风格一直在变啊
最终能保证我能到达我的目目标点
其实这个在航空和航海上还是非常勇的
海上有什么东西
有洋流
对不对
想想在那个浪漫的大航海时代
大家没有GPS的时候
我怎么去导航
能够精准地到达一个海岛
这件事情其实还是很很很厉害的一件事情
所以这个算法的
就是在我们这里面用的一个核心是什么呢
就是说如果我们收到了一个网络包
我们知道我现在已经跟这个
你的真实状态已经不一样了
时候我怎么去追你
有两种追法
一种追法是说
因为我知道我现在的位置姿态跟你不一样
我直接朝朝着你这个姿态去追
对不对
那这地方会出什么问题诶
我追到你的时候
你其实已经到另外一个姿态了对吧
所以这个时候呢我必须要预判你的动作
对不对
所以DCI的这个在我们这里的算算法的思想
就是说我怎么去预判别人下一步的动作
那这里面的话讲一个大名鼎鼎的算法叫PROJECTIVE
velocity blending对吧
PVB它的核心的思想是什么呢
就是说当我诶这个地方稍微有一点点小高能
大家如果看不懂没有关系
因为但是换气算法是个很经典的算法
而且大家如果要写到这样的同步的时候
有很多的资料可以去查
我这里面就跟大家讲一个最核心的一个思想
就是说当我现在发现我的位置
就是经过了一段时间之后
诶
我发现我在点PP0对吧
我的速度是V0
然后呢我再往前走
这个时候呢我突然收到了一个包
这个包告诉我说
哎哥们儿
你错了
其实呢你真实的位置应该在这个P01撇点
对吧
你的速度呢应该也在V01撇
你这时候还收到了一个A01撇的加速度
那大家想想看诶
那我是不是经过了一个就是一个固定时间之后
我们假设这个时间叫tb啊
这个b stands for what呢
就是代表的是blending对吧
就是经过了某一个时间之后
我的心的位置是不是在PT1撇
等于你当前的就是我收到你这个包
告诉我当前的精准位置对吧
加上当前的真实的速度
和当时真实速度的加速度的这个时间平方对吧
这这个公式应该是非常简单
我当时第一次看
我记得我当时我第一次看到公式的时候
我说这是什么公式
后来一想
这不就是牛顿第一第二定理嘛
对不对
就是速度加速度的变化嘛对吧
很简单
就是诶我就知道啊
其实经过了一个固定
比如说一个从现在的T0到TB那个时间之后
你实际上应该出现在那个PT撇那个点
那我不幸的是说在我的客户端里面
诶你的位置还在P0这个点
你的速度还是V0对吧
那我接下来要做的事情是什么呢
我不就是找一条曲线
让我能够着你吗对吧
仔细想想
这个算法是不是很简单好
那具体怎么去构它呢
其实dead recounting这个这个PVB的这个算法
其实可以这么说
非常的简单粗暴
他说OK我假设我提个要求
就是在这个一个时间固定的时间间隔里面
比如说我希望在tb的时候
你就B就指的是blending
就是大B的时候我就要追上你
那实际上呢我就在这个时间轴里面
我做两个差值
第一个差值是什么呢
我对我的速度进行差值
那我就希望我的速度
因为这里面我会假设我的速度
5月嘛我就打
我就希望等到了那个就是说到tb的时候
我的速度跟你一样
那其实就是个线性差值对吧
第二件事情呢
诶我要对我的位置进行价值
这里面就有一个有趣的trick了
就是说因为啊当我没有收到你的新包的时候
其实呢这个这个这个particle
它自身也会受到一个速度或者加速度的影响
对吧
它会如果没有收到那个新包
它是不是沿着上面那个红色的线去走
对不对
他会这样走下去
但是呢因为我收到了你的包
所以我就知道说你在那个tb那个时间的话呢
你会沿着那个绿色的线
走到那个新的PT1撇的那个点
这里面
注意这里的一撇就是假设是真实的位置
而没有加一撇
就表示是我这边复制你的位置
那我其实最核心的方法是什么呢
就是我在这个就是T0到TB之间的时候
我线性的在两个位置之间依次的进行差值
一开始的时候用我的聘礼
到后面逐渐逐渐逐渐逐渐逐渐逐渐
我越来用你条绿色线的那个数值
其实看上去数学很高深
但实际上就是一个非常简单的线性差值
但是这样一个差值的好处是什么呢
就是说我们不会看到这个物体的位置
瞬间的被变掉
他是逐步逐步的诶追上了那个目标点的位置
而且呢大家注意这里面有个细节
就是说这个PPPPB的算法的话呢
它并不符合动力学原理
它其实就是对位置进行一个非常生硬的差值
所以的话理论上讲的话呢
他有可能出现一些
就是它的速度和加速度一直在变对吧
但这不重要
重要的是说我最重要的是
到最后我的到了那个时时间的
tb的那个目标点的时候
哎我的位置也给你重合了
我的这个就是速度也跟你重合了
对吧
加速度我就换成你的了
那我们俩就一致了嘛
对不对
那么这个时候如果来了个新包的话
那我们的结果
如果你在这过程中没有发生新的变化的话
我们的结果其实是一致的
这就是这个带康尼的一个核心思想
但这个方法呢其实他的挑战是什么
等你在tb的时间追到之后
诶新的包来了
你发现在这过程中间哎又发生了一些新的变化
其实它的位置又发生变化了对吧
所以说你仔细看看这个它的实现
就是你会看到一条啊蓝色的曲线
就是你真实的运动轨迹
你一直在尝试追那条绿色的线
而绿色的线呢是真实的
就是author在的玩家的这个在世界上的移动
而你在这个RPC端移动的话
总是尽可能smooth的
就是尽可能平滑的
但是呢一直在努力的追求着那个哈
就是那个真实世界的那个就是AUTHORIZON的移动
其实我们以前在做一些网
网络同步的debug的时候
观察这两条曲线的这个走动的时候
是特别有意思的
有的时候你怎么记bug
它
我会在authors端反向的把那个就是rap
RAPC端的这个数据传回来
然后两边进行比较
看两条曲线的这种重合度
大概多久能追得上
包括我们会加上一些固定的一些网络延迟
我们会看这个延迟的情况下
这个会不会让DCI算法会出问题
所以大家如果有兴趣写这一趴的话
这里面还有很多很有趣的小trick
让你这个效果更好
我今天这里面给大家介绍的还是最简单的算法
那么这个这个算法的话呢
其实大家理解了这个最核心的思想就可以了
其实到后面的话会有很多小的变种
帮你去解决各种各样的小边界情况好
这其实就是那个外插值的一个一个想法
那么其实对于赛车这样的游戏的话
外插值是一个非常必要的一个东西
但是外插值呢其实也会有问题
比如说当我们发现对这个世界进行碰撞的时候
对吧
比如两辆车要撞起来的时候
你也在外差值
我也在外插值
那我们有可能就是说
虽然我们其实已经撞到一起了
但是呢因为你的位置是外插值过来的
你会发现它就不管不顾的插进了我的车头里面
对吧
你会发现诶这两个的行为就很奇怪
而且呢因为就是大家知道
我记得我在那个就是物理那节课讲过
就是说我们在做这个刚体动力学的时候
会发现那个server会有一个有一次的问题
就是说当你发现两个缸体
事实上已经发生穿插的时候
很多物理引擎会给他们一个很大的力
会把那个物体猛地推开来
所以本来你觉得是一个不是特别重的
一个一个一个碰撞
但结果你发现整个东西被弹飞了
大家想象一下
你们在玩一些带那么一丢丢
物理模拟的网游的时候
有没有经常会发现这样的bug
就是A看似两个两个东西只是轻轻地撞在一起
但是你会发现它非常恐怖的弹开来了
如果发现发生这种情况的话
那就是有可能就是A那个对方的游戏
可能用了外差值的一些算法
然后呢
物理的两个那个就是那个他们两个actor
真的穿插了
穿插了之后
物理引擎的话会反向的给一个很大的利普
他们推开了
这个有很多时候可能就是这个原因
那么对于这种情况怎么去处理呢
其实这个问题首先我要跟大家讲一下
非常复杂
挺难的
真的很难啊
这基本上你会针对不同的游戏
比如说你做个赛车游戏
你做个飞机游戏对吧
你作为一个boating的游戏
那你都要单独考虑和设计过
那这里面有一个非常简单的一个思想
就是说我会在客户端提前的进行物理的检测
也就是说
其实如果我在我的客户端已经检测到了
我已经和某一个
比如说啊
强或者是另外一个物体发生碰撞的时候
我就会把这个就是位置同步的权利
从网络同步
和他的那个
比如说DCI的这个这个这个外差值的这些算法
切换回什么呢
切换为物理引擎的算法
这里面是有一个switching的
但是呢他可能是一瞬间切给物理了
然后呢过了一段时间之后
我再逐渐的把这个过程回还给你
比如说像那个就是这里面我们举的例子
就是说啊watch dog
看门狗里面它的假定是说撞车之后
如果我没记错
好像是一秒钟之后
我们逐步的把这个就是这个位置控制权
交还给这个来自于网络端的消息
这样确保我们的世界状态是同步的
那一秒里面其实很多事情我就不能动了对吧
那完全交给我本地就是client端的物理来结算
那这里面其实会导致一个问题
就是说我们不同客户端的
这个物理模拟的结果是不一样的
我还记得大家还记得
我在上一节课讲到物理的deterministic的时候
讲过一件事情
就是说诶你输入条件有那么一丢丢的变化
比如说一辆车被撞飞的时候
可能有一个是这样
这样这样飞掉了另外一个世界
你模拟手这个车是这样这样飞掉了
他俩的位置不会相差的非常大对吧
这里面又很麻烦
所以其实呢在很多的引擎里面
如果我们真的要处理这件事情的话
是挺复杂的
比如说有的算法是说诶
我预测到你可能要撞了对吧
那我首先就把你这个那个
好像是那个那段时间的玩家在控制
我都给你关掉
当然这没有个假设
就是说人类的反应时间不会快过100ms对吧
就算电竞选手
好像也很难超过100ms的反应速度
所以我如果在前50ms
我已经判断你要这个撞车的时候
诶
我全部交给双方的差值
而且位置同步起来
这样大家的结果尽可能的是一致吧
所以这里面是有很多很难的一些trick在里面
但是这里面跟大家讲的这个事情
就是说
当我们真的用外差值去做这样的一个
一个一个应用的时候的话呢
哎大家一定要考虑各种各样的边界情况
这就是做网游的困难
就是网游大家记住啊
就是如果你做个单机游戏做的很漂亮
很多很复杂的这种哎呀这个物理效果啊
你觉得很厉害啊
但是如果把这件事情做到一个online game里面
而且这个东西还能够就真正的跟game play
结合在一起的话
其实这是一个在设计上非常挑战的一个问题
好这就是外差值
其实外差值的话呢也是一个非常重要的系统
所以其实啊这两种差值
对于我们一开始抛出的问题
就是如何在网游里面去同步玩家的位移
是一个基础性的算法
那么这两个应用的场景呢也是不一样的
比如说内差呢一般会应用在
就是说玩家会经常进行各种各样的瞬间的移动
或者说突然很大的加速度
我想问大家一个问题
你们觉得什么情况下玩家的加速度会比较大
大家会会不会觉得诶我开一个跑车游戏
加速度很大对吧
但其实这是一个错觉
实际上的话
如果我现在是个赛车游戏的话
即使你开的最好的跑车
它的加速度啊
实际上也就那么回事
顶多一秒
比如说这个这个百公里三秒
百公里百公里两秒对吧
也就那么回事了
但是的话呢其实在这个游戏里面
真正加速度最大的是什么呢
是我们讲的controller
什么东西
就是玩家自己
因为我们很多时候
大家在操控游戏里的角色的时候
我们要求角色很灵活
很有响应感
实际上在那里面角色的运动是反物理的
我们的加速和减速几乎是瞬时的
哎这个跟大家感觉不一样的呀
大家会觉得我们不是有个提速的过程
其实不是的
如果我们真实的按人类的提速过程
去做到游戏里面的话
你会觉得那个角色很粘滞
就是你会觉得操作手感不好
所以其实包括我们的角色
很多时候有那种什么哎瞬间位移啦
突然一下跳高了
其实在游戏里面角色跳起来或者是落地
他很多时候它的加速都是反物理的
因为如果真是按物理的gravity那个系数的话
你会觉得很怪
所以说所以在很多FPS游戏里面
在MOBA游戏里面
我们一般用interpolation内差值比较多
因为内插值的好处是什么呢
相对比较稳定
它不会外
也因为外差时它其实是个危险的嘛
你要去predict未来
所以有的时候会进入到一些我们不希望的状态
比如说外插值
有时候会把你插到墙里面去了
或者插到一个死胡同里面去了
就很麻烦
就是有些游戏写的不好
就会出现什么情况
我们用了外插
结果呢
那个角色自己
OSA团觉得自己可以在世界里走来走去
但是在ROPA段的话
那个家伙已经钻到了墙的那头
过会儿又被拉回来了
你看起来也很奇怪
但是这里面解决方法也是有的
比如说我可以本地还会做个物理检测
保证它不会穿墙对吧
那么另外那么如果外查呢
一般适用于什么样的游戏呢
就是诶这个它这个整个运动啊
是符合物理学规律的
比如说我们做一个像开船的游戏
开车的游戏对吧
你看着它很复杂
但是呢这个船的加速也好
车的加速也好
包括给了给低音加速下
你调它ROTTO就是它的这个这个油门的话
它实际上整个的位置速度变化
都是符合物理学规律的
这样的话我对他的未来的prediction其实是准的
所以这个时候的话呢
唉我们基本上是能够用外插的方法
去对它进行插值对吧
这个其实是有道理的
就是说我举个例子吧
就比如比如说我们要做一个自动瞄准的一个
远程武器
让我去打辆车的话
这个车一般不会疯狂的
一会儿加速
一会减速
其实很难
所以我其实很容易做一些提前量计算
把它打中
但是我要打一个人的话
这个人一块儿翻滚
一会左摇右摆
其实你做体向量的计算的时候
很多时候很难打中
他也是这个道理
那么实际上在真实的游戏里面的话呢
就是说呃
我们有的时候也会把两种算法合到一起
比如说我们做一个像战地这样的游戏对吧
那我们可以对角色移动的时候
我们用的是内插
这样的话确保它的安全性
但是呢当角色上了载具之后
载具
因为它符合我们的物理学原理啊
那我们载具可以用外插的方法
所以说真实的在游戏的场景中的话呢
这两件事事情是会混合在一起用的
也是一个
这就跟我们上次讲了一个什么
真同步和状态同步一样的对吧
所以大家千万不要就是我还是讲这句话
就是大家在学游戏引擎的时候
千万不要陷入到这种甜豆浆咸豆浆之争
只要是一个方法
它产生了
它一定有它的这个应用场景
而且呢在真实的游戏世界里面的话呢
就是我们认为基本上每一件事
每一个方法都有它的应用场景的
而且很多时候拿来主义能解决问题就是好方法
OK好
所以讲到这一趴的话
同学们大概知道了
哎
我们的这个角色
终于知道怎么在网游里面彼此同步了
否则你如果没有不知道这套算法的话呢
那个角色看上去就很很诡异
好那我们知道这个东西的时候
接下来我们下一件要具体的问题是什么呢
我们怎么去打中别人叫hate registration对吧
这个词registration这个词是个专业说法
就是我们怎么把这个击中的这个信息
互相能够对齐好
那为什么这件事情是很重要的
就是我们在打CSGO也好
打这个设计也好
我们觉得自己是枪神
那把我叫砰一枪
爆头特别爽
但是在一个真实的online游戏里面
爆头这件事情其实比大家想象的还要复杂得多
首先当这个敌人出现的时候
他首先要经过一段时间同步到这个
经过一个RTT
半个RTT同步到哪
同步到服务器
但服务器呢他很坏
他也不是马上处理
他还先buffer一下
对不对
在上节课讲过服务器的很多时候
它会Buff一起这个状态
然后呢在传递给你
好
服务器传给我的时候呢
哎我又要buffer1段
那个这个又要经过一段时间
RTT到我这儿对吧
好到我这儿了
我又不是马上就看见
大家想到我们很多时候
本地也会buffer一下网络的状态啊
对不对
比如说你用的INTERLATION
比如说是一个啊距内插值的这样状态同步的话
那我还做过INTERLATION
诶
这个时候我才能看到这个老哥
出现在我的画面里了
然后你这个时候再再经过
你自己的一个反应时间
说来我一枪爆头对吧
大家想想看
你本来觉得是对方一瞬间出现在你的面前
然后你机智果敢的一枪把对方头打爆了
实际上在真实的物理世界里面
这中间已经发生了无数次的
时间的偏移和延迟了
那么在这么多的不确定性下的话
我怎么知道我我真的能打中这个人的头呢
对吧
我说我打中了
别人怎么信我呢
所以这其实就是在这个网络游戏里面的
这个命中判定
实际上是一个非常难的一个问题
那这件事情难在哪里
我第一个问题就是敌人到底在哪里对吧
还是搬出这张很经典的这张图
对不对
你发现就是说那个灰色的
就是那个半透明的
是别人现在真实的位置
也就是对方是那个玩家自己跑的位置
然后呢中间那个半半透明的那个是什么呢
诶是这个我们的server端
server端呢稍微慢那么一点点
但是它勉强能追得上诶
然后呢再到传递到我这的时候
这个老哥是那个时我看到的是那个十的部分
他已经相对于那个真实的玩家已经落后了
至少有两三个身位
现在看上去大概有4~5个身位以上的
这样的一个时间的距离
所以说这样的这么大的一个距离的话
我们到底怎么算命中他了对吧
那么第二件事情就是说诶对方这样移来移去
我怎么就打中他了呢
而且对方的位置在同步的时候
很多时是不稳定的
然后还有一个更让人觉得难受的一个问题
就是说诶现在有一个掩体
一个cover对吧
这个老哥我现在看见他的
他在那个掩体之外
我一枪命中他
但是他觉得我已经进了掩体对吧
他肯不愿意被你打死
那这件事情怎么去解决呢
所以说其实当你在网游里面
你看到对方一个人头的时候对吧
尤其你的弹道不是瞬间的
你有的时候可能是有一个project
就是说诶我有个飞行的过程对吧
如果呢我还要加上一个重力加速度
我的弹道还有下坠
大家如果玩战地的话
就知道那个战地里的狙击枪
它是有下垂的对吧
那好了呀
那这个时候我怎么样才能做一个完美的
这个是一枪开了完美的一枪能够命中敌人呢
其实这就是hit registration
也就是说射击命中判定的话
最核心要尝试解决的问题
哎注意啊
这里面我讲了一个词叫尝试
什么意思
就是我事实上认为
虽然我这节课后面
我记得这下面会跟大家讲很多的方法
但是我个人认为
这个问题到目前为止
还是没有得到一个完美的解决
因为确实是上帝老人家太完美了
我们就做不到
对吧好
那我们就讲这个问题
我们怎么去解他
所以这里面就引入了著名的这个这个这个这个
hit registration的概念
那么黑就是黑
hit registration的话呢
在我的理解中呢
它其实啊
就是在一个online的一个非常不确定的网络环境下
我们让所有的client能够
关于我到底有没有命中我的目标达成一个共识
哎注意啊
这里面讲的是共识
而不是这个fact或者reality
也就是说其实啊在一个网络延迟的环境下
你开了一枪到底有没有击中目标
这件事情并不存在
一个ground truth
就是一个真实的解
诶
这个是个很让人绝望的一个结论啊
因为因为确实是因为在每一个人世界里面
你开枪的时间点
对方和环境所在的状态
对方所在的位置都是不一样的
你这时候开了一枪之后
那我们怎么说你一定能打中这个人呢
特别像我们特别喜欢的那个爆头
对不对
所以呢在这种情况下
我们既然没有ground truth
所以大家最重要的是达成一个共识
说你到底算打中了还是没打中对吧
所以这就是head registration的一个核心的目标对
那么his registration的话呢
实际上有两种大的解决方法的流派
第一种方法呢哎比较简单
就是我们的客户端来决定
这个时候呢我们一般不叫his registration
我们叫head detect detection
或就是说诶我的射击检测就好了
而没有如果我们交给服务器端来处理的话
我们一般叫它head registration
就是说诶这个我们的叫击中哇
这个registration怎么翻译的啊
不管了
反正就大家记住这个词就好了对吧
那么我们先讲一个呃
最简单的就是说我们在客户端去判定它
其实客户端判定的游戏啊
一般来讲它有一些特征
比如说大家特别喜欢的这个PUBG对吧
这个有100多个玩家在一个世界里面
那么多的玩家
其实你说一枪打中
我
让这100多个玩家跟我的服务器一起
达成一个共识啊
好像有那么一丢丢的比较难对吧
所以呢PUBG的话
我不知道他现在最新的版本
至少早期的版本它是用客户端去做的
哎这里面我后面会讲的就是
为什么PUBG有那么多的挂对吧
大家听完这个section
大家知道为什么它有很多的挂了对吧
另外一个比如说这个世界非常的动态
非常的复杂
比如像战地
战地里面的话
有一有几座的时候
你可以把墙整个拆了
我记得有一座我特别印象特别深
就是一个屋子
我可以一一块一块的把这屋子整个拆了
那时候我就觉得嗨的不得了对吧
然后呢我可以通过我拆掉屋子的那个墙的边缘
躲在那边给别人射击
那这个世界如果是非常的动态
有大量的破坏的时候
其实呢我们会认为它更适合在客户端直接判断
那客户端判断呢它其实就非常的简单了
也就是说我就是一个head Scout
就是我去看一下我这个能不能打中
那么注意
这里面就是那个对于这里面讲的设计游戏
specific了
就是说它有三种不同的弹道对吧
一种是说我开枪
我直接设一条速度无限快的一条射线
注意啊
这里的速度是无限快
你比光还快
就是我开枪的一瞬间
只要你在我那条射线上
你就死了对吧
那这个的话呢就是说呃
很很多早期的设计游戏是这么设计的
那么一些比较
这个就相对追求这种真实感的游戏的话呢
我们会追求说诶你的子弹还是要飞过去的对吧
最早比如说我做的halo
halo里面那个子弹很多时候飞的是直线
但是呢有些弹药它是打的是那个
它是有个飞行过程
所以你有的时候会展现一下我的秀操作
就是看见子弹过来
我会尝试去躲一躲
其实大家如果打设计游戏就知道
如果对方的弹速比较慢的时候
特别是那种什么rocket launcher过来的时候
你觉得自己顺势来个翻滚测试
让过的时候
你内心的那种那种肾上腺素分泌
会让你觉得特别的爽对吧
所以说这也是我们的乐趣之一
那么在一起更加拟真的游戏里面的话呢
就是他会加上一个这个抛物线对吧
这个其实是我个人还是蛮喜欢的
我觉得这个就是因为我我我我
我觉得射箭是一件很爽的运动嘛对吧
那么其实说其实
因为因为我们的这个人类是狩猎出来的
所以说我们天然的对这种抛物线弹道
是有一种呃很很发自本能的一种愉悦感
所以说其实在你在客户端的话
你用这三种不同的弹道都没有问题
为什么
因为你做的都是对的
那么其实客户端呢它的算法本身是非常的简单
就是说我只以你本地看到的东西为准
就是你一枪打过去
然后我你你在你本地看到对方在什么位置
就是什么位置
你这样的好处是什么呢
它非常的准确
非常的符合人的直觉
所以我做那种很精准的爆头啊
做一些非常复杂的操作都是可以的
所以说基本上在客户端判定的射击游戏
一般来讲都是你射击手感比较好的游戏
但不能说是最好
因为手感好
还有很多很复杂的原因的来来影响它好
那是不是你客户端说诶我打中了就一定打中了
这个呢
当然了
我们可以这么干对吧
但是呢作为一款网游呢
有的时候我们还是不会那么容易的放弃治疗
所以在server端的话呢
我们会做一个过程叫做verification
我们会做一个验证
这个验证其实一般来讲做的都不会特别的麻烦
因为我既然已经选择了相信客户端对吧
那我怎么办呢
那我很简单说诶
你客户端你把你开枪的位置告诉我一下对吧
然后呢你告诉我你到底打中了谁
你到底打中他哪一点
你发给我
发给我之后呢
server就会说哎
首先我验证一下你开枪的点是不是假的对吧
比如说如果在服务器端
你的位置和你开箱的点差了10万8000里对吧
那我知道你在作弊
那我给你把它踢掉
然后呢你说你打中了张三的哪个点诶
我说这个
如果我发现那个你的被击中的那个家伙
和你击中那个家伙的位置点差的也很大
那你可能也是在乱说对吧
那这个地方我也认为你可能在作弊
对不对
你比如你本地可能修改了那个角色的位置
比如说你写个外挂
把所有的敌人都拉到你的面前
然后你一枪一枪把别人枪毙掉对吧
那这个我肯定能detect出来
最后一个的话呢
如果这两个都没有作弊好
我接下来看
就是说从你的开箱点到这个你的hit point之间
就shoot point和hit point之间
哎我们连一条线看看中间有没有这个障碍物
因为你想想如果我做个CSGO这样的游戏的话
你说OK我开了全图透视的这个外挂
然后呢我我确实是真的打了那个人
但是的话我根本不管所有的墙和掩体对吧
那这个这个我们的服务器端表示说唉
这种低级的问题你还是不能糊弄我的
那我还是能帮你检测到
就是我做一个简单的recasting
就知道你有没有穿过墙体去打了别人对吧
但是CSGO里面有些墙是可以好像可以打穿的
Ok anyway
所以的话呢
这个其实是在这个就是客户端的这个
这个这个就是hit detection的时候
我会做一个非常简单的这样的一个检验
但是真实的就是说就算是一个客户端的这个
检验的游戏里面的话
呃
我们实际上的真实的情况比这个要复杂很多
我这边举个简单的例子啊
比如说大家看了大名鼎鼎的这是什么
这是守望先锋
对不对
守望先锋诶
他就是选择了在客户端做检测
所以手腕的设计手感确实是不错的对吧
那人家是怎么做的呢
这里给大家看看这个这个很很神奇的一件事情
就是说你在客户端说你打中了一个人呢
实际上他在他的服务器上会做一个检测
说你到底有没有打动他
但是呢他也知道说哎呀
我们彼此之间的网络的情况非常的复杂
对不对
很多不可信
他就以那个人为核心
做了一个box
这个box可能做的比他本人大很多啊
就是红色框的那个区域诶
大概是那么大的一个box
说只要你打中那个box
我就算你打中了
这个听上去大家是不是呃好像有点反直觉啊
这么高级的一个设计游戏
原来这么粗暴的就判断了我能打中
这个
让我极大的激发了我写外挂的这个这个动力
对不对
但是再次再次说一遍啊
外挂本身是违法的啊
大家不要去碰它
但是呢确实啊
但是我相信啊
他的防范的方法还有很多
包括现在最新的守望二
我不知道他用了什么技术啊
这至少是他自己公开资料讲师
我是这样去做他的
这个就是这个这个服务器端的verification
所以这个里面反过来讲一件什么事情呢
就是说如果你选择了相信客户端
去做这个hit detection的话
在服务器端的检测检测呢
我很多时候基本上是靠蒙的哈哈
我只能做一些呃
基本勉强能说得过去的这样的验证
然后其他的我只能交给这个
我相信这个客户端
但是其实没有那么简单
因为我们为了防止用户作弊
其实我们会在本地做很多的这个防作弊措施
后面会具体的讲
那么所以这个其实就是这个在客户端做检测的
这个方法
那这个方法的话呢
其实刚才也讲了
就是它的好处是什么呢
就是非常的高效
非常的准确对吧
那你真的打的很爽
对不对
第二个的话呢
他真的还高效
为什么高校呢
因为他很多计算比较麻烦的计算机
全部在本地做完了
所以在服务器那边其实是比较轻松的
你想要做一个RECOSTING
这个是很快的嘛对吧
但是效率很高
但是呢他最大的问题就是
我们讲的就是非常的这个不安全
因为客户端一旦被破解
或者说网络包一旦被破解的话
它就非常麻烦
那真的要做很多特殊的处理
我才能勉强避免你的作弊啊
这里面我给大家讲一个非常简单的这种
如果是客户端检测游戏怎么去作弊的方法
这个方法是这样的
有一种方法叫luck switch
什么意思呢
就是说哎呀这个这个叫小朋友学坏了啊
就是你可以用软件也好
用硬件
硬件的话
你把你的网络当场给断一下
这样他就没有新的包过来了
没有新的抱过来的时候
你面前的敌人是不是就暂时停了一下
对不对
诶
你这个时候一枪一枪的往你面前
时间静止的敌人爆头
然后呢再过比如说一秒钟或者是0.5秒
把这个网络再接回去
诶
这个时候因为这个时间很短嘛
所以一般服务器不会判断你掉线对吧
但是你完美的完成了这个一次的
这个这个什么枪毙爆头诶
这个时候服务器导弹就受到了一个
相对真实的说
你把人家爆头的这样的一个一个一个现状了
特别是如果对方移动没有那么大的时候
唉你真的可以这么干的
所以说这其实哈是客户端
这个就是检测的时候
真的是玩家有各种各样很奇怪的骇客的方法
比如说还有一个方法
就是比如说我们弹药量是有限的对吧
但是的话呢客户端那个发出这种hit的
有的时候可以如果写的不好的话
它可以用无限的弹药
我们自己写写那个online游戏的时候
我们也会遇到这样的一个bug对吧
也是因为客户端那个detection本身的不可靠性
所以说这其实就是cosk detection的问题
所以这其实是一个很不安全的一个方法
那如果客户端很不安全
那我们怎么办
我们把这个击中命中检测放到服务器端
那这里面就出现了一个很有意思的问题
就是说在服务器端你看到了这个人的位置
一定会比你在我本地看到的这个这个这个慢
对吧啊快
因为服务器端这个老哥已经跑到
比如说跑进掩体了
但是在我的世界里面
他还没有跑进掩体
对不对
这个时候我我看到这个世界这个人没有跑进你
我想一枪把他毙了
但是的话呢服务器端说他已经跑进去了
他认为你这箱开的是无效的
那尤其是我要进行精准瞄准的
这样的一个射击游戏的时候
是不是你永远也打不中移动中的目标呢
对吧就是如果放在客户端
我对方在移动
我能击中它
但是如果在服务器端的话
只要对象在运动
除非我知道服务器端
那个人真实的位置已经往前走了
否则的话我是打不中他的
这其实就是这个啊
放在服务器端一个最基本的一个问题
那这个问题怎么解呢
哎这里面的话呢
就要引入一个大名鼎鼎的概念了
叫lack composition
延迟补偿
这个听上去这个名字听上去就非常的高端
叫延迟补偿对吧
我补偿个啥呢
其实他补他的想法其实非常的简单
就是说当我收到了一个客户端
说我开枪了的一个指令的时候
我不是说马上把我现在假设我是服务器啊
我收到了说诶那个张三开了一枪
想打李四对吧
没问题
我当时我不知道他要打谁
我就说张三开了一枪
我知道他设计的位置
设计的点设计的方向给我了
这个时候呢我不会简单的说
因为我现在的状态
就是现在状态里面李斯的位置去检测一下
有没有被这个弹道给击中
因为什么呢
因为如果李四在动的话
在张三那边的这个李斯的位置
肯定比我这边感受到的位置要慢
为什么呢
因为李四的位置是要通过我才同步给他的
对不对
可能会慢个100ms以上对吧
那么好
那怎么办
诶
公平起见
我把这个我这里的状态的时钟往回拨
拨回倒回去
100ms
100ms之前
李四在哪
哎
我这个时候跟这根射线进行检测
如果我发现我这边存在一秒100ms钟之前的
这个李斯的位置的时候
真的能被他打中的话
我认为张三同志
你打的是对的
是这个这句话用更简单的话一起解释
就是说我猜测在每一个shooter开枪者的时候
你开枪的那一瞬间
你的世界是什么状态
虽然我作为一个服务器
我并不知道你是真想要
但是我可以根据延迟
根据我们的算法
我可以去猜测这件事情
所以这个都想这个思想叫什么呢
叫做延迟补偿
但是大家想想看
如果我想去真的实现这样的一个延迟补偿的
这个算法的话
是不是我有个前提
就是说在我的服务器上
我的server的这个这个世界的这个state的
这个每一个tick的时候
我是不是要对state的做一个快照对吧
我要存一段时间
这样的话
比如说唉有的客户端是50ms
有的客户端是100mm
有的客端150ms
我呢都能够找得到对应的过去的人
所以说呢其实这个对服务器里面有个要求
就是说我要对世界各个这个状态进行一个快照
我要形成一个buffer
这也是延迟补偿的一个基础
好那更具体的讲这个case的话
这张图看的就比较清楚了
就是说哎当这个服务器在这个位置的时候
我蓝色的是我现在这个在跑的人
就是我的目标人物对吧
红色的就是那开枪的坏人对吧
他要打打别人
那么蓝色它开始在从位置一移动的时候
实际上它首先到我的这个服务器的话
已经有一个延迟了对吧
哎然后呢再传到他的rap段
就是那个红色的那个
就是要开枪的那个地方的话
又有一个延迟
其实呢还不只能延迟
大家记住
如果我们之前讲过是PS游戏
很多时候是什么
是内插值对吧
内插值是什么呢
我还要去等一段时间
我对你的位置进行插值之后
我才能得到你的位置
所以这样的话呢
其实这个时候我在红色那个地方
我看到的时间其实已经很落后了
好那个红色那个玩家说
OK我看到你了
我开始开枪了
砰开枪开枪的时候呢
诶这个开枪的消息也不是立刻马上能告诉server了
他还得经过一个延迟才能传到我的server
所以当server最后收到那个红色的玩家开枪的时候
你发现没有
蓝色玩家目录到那个点的时间
已经差了10万8000里了
那好那那个蓝色玩家你真的你到哪
我们不care对吧
这个这个我们能理解
但是的话呢这个就是说至少在我server里面的话
我也跟我的状态也差了10万8000里
所以说这个时候如果用server那边的
这个蓝色玩家的位置
去做那个那个他的那个就是射击机检测的话
肯定是错的
所以那个composition的这个核心思想是什么
诶
我要把我的时间就rewind time
我把时间倒回什么呢
就是我当前的时间减去你的各路的latency对吧
还减去什么呢
你客户端如果采取的内插值
因为我们知道你们因为我们是同一个游戏
所以我知道你内插值用的什么算法
所以我知道你的interpretation offset是多少
所以我就可以把时间拨回到那个点
然后我就能猜测在你开枪的那一瞬间
在红色的那个客户端
你看到的位置在哪里
这个听上去稍微有那么一丢丢的抽象
但大家只需要知道他的思想就可以了
其实这个思想
其实我觉得还是一个蛮聪明的一个思想
这里面这张图就是一个真实游戏的一个案例
就是说其实那个角色就是你拿着枪的
就是诶蓝色那个玩家我要开枪了
对不对
诶那个红色的玩家呢
就是我在我看过了那个红色玩家是一啊
它真实的其实呢已经跑到了那个前面一点点了
但是的话呢在服务器上
这里面的话就是说啊
如果我没记错的话
因为字看的不是特别清楚
那个如果red的话
其实是那个你的你的
当前的那个就是玩家在服务器端
我倒回去的时候所在的位置
而红色的话呢
实际上是诶在你射击者的世界里面
看到他的位置
所以这样的整个时间我倒回去的时候
你会发现如果网络的波动基本上是稳定的
就是网络不会lens
也不会一直在波动
那么我们对服务器的这个ticking的周期
和客户端TK的周期
包括客户端进行差值的算法
是全部对焦过的话呢
其实la composition是能给你一个
相对好的一个结果的
这也是为什么就是说像那个就是有些设计游戏
敢采用这种就是说啊这个状态同步的方法去做
其实也是有基于这样的一个
就是啊敢敢采取这种就是hit registration
就是服务器端做设计检测的原因
就是因为我能够对你客户端的状态进行补偿
那这个补偿有个很大的好处
就是说如果客户端进行一些攻击的时候
诶我可以选择无视对吧
你比如说刚才我讲的那个你突然拔网线的话
我也不管你要拔就拔
对不对
反正我预测的那个延迟就是那样的
你肯定是打不中的
对所以说这是like composition的话
一个很核心的一个思想
那这里面有个细节
就是说你就是根据你不同的算法
比如说你是用内插值呀
外插值呀
其实在这个LOCAUATION里面
你都要单独的处理
实际上大家如果真的去写一个
实战的游戏的时候
你会发现这里面要处理的情况真的非常的多
比如说你用了外插值
还再加上本地的一些物理检测
对不对
诶这个方法好像又变得更复杂了对吧
那这里面我就不展开了
反正我自己要写这个东西的话
我也写的头疼
肚子疼对好
所以的话呢这个地方的话就是诶
尝试已经解决了我们所有的问题
是我们很开心了
但是呢实际上我为什么要讲说has registration
到目前为止
我不认为它完美地解决了
比如说这里面一个最经典的问题就是cover
就是掩体问题对吧
掩体问题分两种
第一种是什么呢
我现在在开阔地
我要躲进掩体
这个时候呢你会发现一个很有意思的事情
就是说我觉得我已经躲到掩体后面了
大家如果玩一些设计游戏
你没有发现
我感觉我已经做了一个完美的躲避了
但是对我躲到掩体后面
被人家一枪打死了
就像一个视频中出现的这个情况
但是为什么呢
其实它还是由这个leg导致的
就是说在对方的客户端里面
你还没有进掩体
所以他在比如说0.1秒
0.2秒开了一枪之后
你的位置已经发生变化了
但是他还是把你打死了
而且这个东西的话呢
因为有like composition对吧
那服务器端
服务器端是以开枪人的那边的世界为准的
这是菲尔的
对不对
所以你就是被打死了
所以说在这样的一种情况
就是如果你躲进掩体的时候
实际上呢这是一个对开枪者有利的一种情况
对吧
那么再讲一个第二种情况
很有意思的
就是说哎我现在我先躲在掩体后
我开始偷窥别人的时候
唉
因为由于legging的原因
其实我已经看到对面来了一个人了
但是呢因为我的位置还没有同步过去
所以在他的世界里面
我还躲在掩体后面
他还看不见我
而且呢我那个时候无论是以发现他呀
还是这个开枪啊
其实我都会抢一个先手的优势诶
大家看到没有
这里面是不是有一个
如果对方用黑特瑞斯生的方法
做这个这个这个做射击命中判定的时候
有一个大家想到了非常棒的一个作弊的方法
对你从掩体后面突然冒出来的时候
其实注意如果网络延迟比较大的话
你就是优势方
为什么呢
因为对方可能在100ms之后才能看到你
但是你已经抢了一个100ms的先手了
所以其实在这个case里面的话
如果冲出来的人是picker对吧
那个在外面假卡住位置
打算mini的人叫holder的话
那其实这个时候呢是冲出来的人
就是掩体后面冲出来的人
他实际上是有优势的
你发现没有
虽然我们讲了
那么多的luck composition的这个算法
但实际上在一个网络的这种延延迟的情况下
他的这个这个宇宙啊
它其实是不对等的
在不同的SCENARO情况下
就是它实际上都会产生了
不同的优势方和劣势方
这也是为什么我们讲作为一个网络游戏
其实非常复杂的一个原因
那么这里面的话呢
比如说我们做一个专业的一个职业的设计
比如FPS游戏的一个竞技比赛的话
一般我们都会选择用局域网
要把延迟控制的足够小
因为啊假设你的延迟只有十几毫秒的话
这个应该还好
但是呢其实这里面还要做一件事情是什么呢
就是说我们会哦这里面我这样把它去掉了
就是我们会怎么
我们比如说一个专业的cs的
一个一个一个一个server的话
我们可能会把server的这个frame rate
这个这个tick rate调得非常高
这样的话
尽可能把每一个环节的延迟都会降下来
这样对双方的选手来讲相对公平一点
所以同学们现在就能理解说
为什么就是如果网络对战游戏做不好的话
很容易就会出现就是某一种操作
它必然有先天优势
也是这个道理
但是呢hit registration呃
他特别是like composition的话
还是一个目前为止最为重要的一种
就是网络同步
这个在网络情况下去同步击中判定的一个方法
O那么这里面还有没有别的方法呢
其实还有一些方法
比如说我们叫做这个能不能用一些hack的方法
能够让大家的命中变得更加的符合我们的认知
有一个最简单的方法是什么呢
哎叫前摇
这个大家肯定没有听这个这个词
如果玩游戏的同学们一定知道我在讲什么对吧
就是当我发动攻击的时候
假设我让角色播放一个非常炫酷的
这个起手动作
哎其实你会觉得这是个表演对吧
而且你也觉得非常的合理
但是呢就那么几帧的起手动作
给我们的网络同步争取了
比如说50ms
100ms
这样的话也能够非常有效的降低
就是在网络的波动情况下
或者网络延迟情况下
我们导致了就是客户端和服务器端状态不同步
的这个latency
所以说很多游戏
特别是啊我们在动作游戏的时候
我会建议就是说大家会做一些设计的前摇
因为前摇这件事情能够给网络同步争取时间
当然了
这个地方要去单独的处理
那么另外一种呢
就是让大家觉得感觉好的方法是什么呢
就是虽然我用的还是这个这个服务器端判定的
这种hate registration
但是呢我在本地首先检测觉得你命中了诶
我假设命中的时候
我先让他播放一个巨大的这个雪花的
这种particle出来对吧
或者一些什么特效
这个时候你在本地的感觉就打击更好
为什么呢
因为否则的话你老等服务器回来的话
你开一枪
你觉得你打中别人了
但是呢你的消息到服务器
服务器算完之后再回来
可能是150ms
200ms钟的时
已经0.2秒之后了
你就会觉得那个感觉很奇怪
就像塑料打空气的感觉诶
所以我在本地先让你把播放出一个
比如说巨大的雪花啊
或者说我让你出现一个
就是说这种这个暴击的这个数字啊
我上次不讲暴击
可以在本地做预算
预算嘛对吧
但是呢这里面有一个细节
就是说这里面所有你想要的特效
这些东西呢它都是让你感受好一点
但是真实的伤害数字我们叫做结算诶
它还是以服务器的计算为准
所以这样的两种方法的话呢
能够让大家的感受会好很多
其实我个人特别推荐的
如果你做一款动作游戏的这个引擎的话
一定要鼓励大家多做前摇
因为前摇的话确实能给网络同步
这个这个这个这个就是说争取很多时间
但是钱要做长了
大家都感受什么
哎呀这个英雄这个技能起手实在太慢对吧
所以的话世界上没有免费的午餐
总是有代价的